Welcome to this freezing cold day.
It's freezing.
That means really cold, by the way.
Body language.
We've got a paintball gun.
Yeah loads of people
have been asking for it,
haven't they?
You've been asking for literally a year.
So we're gonna shoot
someone with this today, or?
Yeah the thing is,
paintball guns are actually
really dangerous, you
have to be really careful
'cause they can-
Idiot.
So what we're gonna do is,
one of us is gonna get shot
in the flesh, which on a day like this,
it's gonna be painful anyway,
so whip out a bit of flesh.
sores.
It's gonna get numb! It's up
to whoever is gonna get shot,
where you get shot.
You can do arsecheek, hands.
I might go for upper arse
Upper arse.
I think I'll go for, sort of, thigh maybe.
So how we gonna decide
Flip a coin?
All right.
So heads I win, tails you lose?
Yeah.
Tails.
You lose.
Damn it
Give me that now.
This is gonna hurt so much.
Revenge!
Can you hit the button off of that?
Yeah yeah, well you're
gonna be on the floor.
Make sure you hit the button.
Because if we have to do
this again I will go mental.
Go mental.
Okay, just so everyone knows,
it's not my actual arsecheek.
It's just upper, it's lower back I'd say.
Lower back.
Lower back flesh. Okay. Are you ready?
Yeah.
Are you ready?
Oh my god.
You're dripping paint
out of your arsecheek!
Oh, it's already-
It's broken the skin there, look at that!
Did it feel good for you too?
Really good!
Yeah?
That really hurt!
I bet it did.
Most painful thing as
of yet on Slow Mo Guys?
No, the most painful thing
was you bonking me in the head
with this hammer, with the sledgehammer.
Is that actually?
Yeah.
Okay, Dan is gonna get
shot in the leg real close.
That's right, the other leg.
I'll just step in the camera.
That hurt more!
It was just like...
Nothing, nothing.
Let's have a look.
It feels fine.
Oh damn! That's pretty gnarly!
You just get those
circular paintball bruises
that nothing else gives
you apart from paintball.
"You've been playing
paintball, haven't you?"
"Yes, yes, I have been."
Both my legs hurt! Both my legs hurt!
Is that your-
That's my "Both of my legs
are hurting" jump dance.
, love it.
Well that was a painful video.
I don't know about you,
but mine hurt a little bit.
I hurt a lot more now
than I did like three
minutes after you shot it.
Yeah.
Well, at least the gun
didn't go off in this-
Ow, my elbow!
Now, that episode was shot
a couple of months ago
and I totally still
have the scar, so yeah,
that was pretty dumb, don't do that.
Now, what I want you to do,
as some of you should do,
is subscribe to "DeepSkyVideos".
It's a new show made by Brady,
the guy that does "Sixty
Symbols" and "Periodic Videos".
It's very cool, a very interesting channel
and I'm linking you right now to a video
about exploding stars!
Everything you need to
know about supernova.
Check it out, click
it. Go! Go, go, go, go!